やっとアニメオタクとして堂々と生活が
できる隠れオタクが持つ特別感がなくなる
和食は非常に健康的だセブンの隣に住む
ことになるから今までと比べて大して
変わらない外国人と付き合ってみたい日本
人がたくさんいるその中にいい恋人になる
人ってあんまりいない日本は先進的な技術
に溢れている80年代の全てのものは綺麗
でよく整理されている義務清掃があるから
だ渋谷のタワーレコードにやっと行ける
ちょっと待ってレコードプレイヤーは
おろかあなたはCDプレイヤーさえ持って
いない日本人は清潔な人が多いあなた
みたいに油で顔がテカテカしている
アメリカ人は非常に目立つとにかく物価が
安い給料も安い日本のUFキャッチャーは
めっちゃ楽しい最初の5回ぐらいは
likeHELLK念願のJPOPライブ
にやっと行けるテバヤからチケットを3倍
の値段で買ったら外国人でもアニメ業界で
働けるアニメ業界のことをよくしていたら
そこで働きたいという気持ちが完全に
なくなる一般的に言うと日本人はとても
健康的だ一般的に言うと日本の事務は回避
が高すぎて設備が少なすぎるWhere
isthebenchPress日本の
ラブ法は独特で楽しいそしてnetfli
&チルよりずっと高い漢字はかなり難しい
けどマスタしたら読む速さがグっと上がる
あカタカナがなければ日本は他の国と比べ
てめっちゃ治安がいいしかしその分自然
災害があるやっと商事のある家に住める壁
が紙でできている家に住むことになる朝の
電車はいつも時間通りに来るそしていつも
死ぬほど混んでいる困った時は外人カード
が使える外人カードを使ってるってバレ
たら腹切りをしなきゃいけない日本の
バラエティ番組は世界一面白いエティ番組
に興味がなくてもテレビ台を払わなきゃ
いけない日本はまだアメリカほどに曲化し
ていないしかしその政治がはすでに同じ
ぐらい腐っている田舎に引っ越せば本当に
ただで空屋がもらえる空屋を住める家に
するために大体1000万円と3年間が
かかる日本の現代のトイレはマジですごい
それが最も必要とされているレストラン
すなわち居酒屋とラーメン屋には日本の
現代トイレはない日本には4つの美しい
季節があるそして花粉症インフルエンザ
寒暖差アレルギーそれぞれの季節に病気が
ある日本は健康保険がびっくりするぐらい
安い税がびっくりするぐらい上がっている
から日本に引っ越したら毎日日本語が
使える1つの会話しかし
ないY